george: And I understand.
george: Hi! My name. Hi! My name is George. I'm one of the testers here at table. Thanks for thanks for going through this workflow workflow thing. I really appreciate it.
george: Today I'll be looking at the today I'll be looking at today. I will be looking at the today. I'll be looking at the table optical platform to see, see, to test for accessibility, test for accessibility, accessibility, and usability, aspect of it, and and see and and see and see if it's and see if.
george: and and and see, and and see, and see, and see.
george: and and see if it's even if overall, if it makes sense and stuff overall overall, it makes sense and and and and it's a it's a is a compatible and good platform overall
george: the the current configuration I'm using to do
george: the current configuration. I'm use assistive technology configuration I'm using today is called go
george: call dragon. Naturally speaking for windows where W, where it's a voice dictation based program that that's able to con control the whole whole that's able, that's able to control the com, able to control.
george: able.
george: able able to control the whole computer. You are using your voice and substituting the the physical physical mouse and keeper. Basically, yeah, okay, to get started. That's to to get started and stuff right off the bat, but right off the bat. But I like the layout of this web layout of the website for sure.
george: the font is very. The font is very big enough and and big enough. So so so it's visible and stuff and and and the bolded letter, and the bolded head, and the bolded heading is is is like the the the font, the font.
george: the fonts between the main heading, and and the deep detail stuff is is divided, divided by the boldness which bo bold boldness, which is on a boldness which is, which which is very good to see, and very visible and and easy to access, easy to all use and stuff.
george: Thanks I mean
george: click next click star tour on
george: hmm!
george: But next I know.
Hmm.
george: hmm! Click next.
Hmm! Alright.
george: But next I'm
george: but next time
george: click! Get started.
george: but get started
george: and
george: show links.
george: Choose to
george:  and mouse
george: 8 one click.
george: Well.
george:  And
george: so I really like the the fact that so I really like the fact that that like during the tour, no, no, no! During the tours.
george: huh!
george: During the tour and stuff. The the the website, highlights.
george: the website, also highlights website. Oh.
george: hmm.
george: hmm, hmm.
george: on
george: the website also highlights the the highlights, the part, the part, part, the parts of the website that that that the parts of the website that they're that they're mainly talking about at the at the at the time. And so so it's easier to view and stuff, which which is that definitely good to see in terms of the
george: in terms of the accessible accessibility, aspect, and and the compatibility with with the program itself. Everything seems to work fine, everything seems to work fine.
george: every every everything. Everything seems to work fine, everything seems to work fine. Besides, the last part of the the the the gets get. You know, the last part of the get started button, where? Where? The where, where.
george: where? I input and multiple where? Where?
george: Well, where I am, where I input in multiple commands. But but it didn't recognize the button for some reason. So so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so.
george: so I have to resort. So I have to resort to the the, the m, the the last mouse, good mouse, could command option, which which which is which I thought I should mention, because, cause it's not as not as consistent, or something like that. So so I figure I should mention that part. Yeah, but
but
george: but in terms of the layout and the Ui itself it it seems very, very. Yeah. I've been
george:  very easy, very easy to navigate, and and and simple and easy to find, and and as everything's pretty visible and big and stuff which is good, it's just just that button itself was was kind of a kind of a a a
george:  alright
george: accessibility in country for sure, a problem problem in country.
george: I'm gonna quickly go to school throughout this course to see
george: to test the usability and accessibility aspect of it again.
george: Click! Start learning.
george: then.
george: -oh.
george:  Scroll down.
george:  hmm!
Scroll down.
george: Oh.
george: scroll down,
george: Scroll up.
george: start scrolling down.
george: stop scrolling.
george: show links well.
george: choose 15
george: show links.
george: Choose 16. Scroll down.
george: show links
george: subless go to sleep.
george: Hmm, hmm.
george:  So this aspect of the page seems seems seems pretty good to go on every aspect of the page pay page seems like a page. Seems like page seems like
page seems accessible, accessible, and stuff
george: accessible and stuff while using the pro and stuff.
george: oh, no, no, no, no!
george: The the the the
george: the left side menu, the left side menu seems zoom seems all accessible, and stuff which is, which is good and easily reachable with the
george: easily written.
george: easily easily reachable with the program and stuff.
george: I also like the fact that the the the I also like the fact that in terms of the in terms of the layout and usability aspect of it, the it's divided is
george: it's divided into different sections. So you know sections with with sections, with the use, with the use of a different call
george: and a different call. a different color font. Okay. Hmm.
george: A different color of choice. So that's very good to see and and and and it pops for pops on the eye, for sure. So so so definitely, definitely, very easy to navigate.
george: 1, 11.
george: But everything else, but everything else in general, with the like, the the links and stuff.
george: the the the the doesn't, the link the links and the button seems to be accessible, accessible, accessible, easy to click and stuff which is good to see. We're gonna continue on as I was
george: doing.
george: But next activity
george: are open.
george: scroll down.
one reason.
george: Umhm.
george: but play
george: click, pause. Hmm, hmm. Okay.
george: click, play.
george: scroll down.
george: scroll up
george: so starts cooling down.
george: stop scrolling show links
george: 2, 17.
george: But pause.
george: Hi! I'm Kate Kelsey. Talk to you about web accessibility in order to talk about web accessibility. We all started to talk about disability, and I wanted to talk to you about my disability
george: hearing impaired, which means I have to wear hearing aids in both 8 years.
george: so so, so, so, so, so, so everything seems, everything seems everything seems quite was. Everything seems, everything seems stuck. So
george: everything.
everything seems
george:  Every week, every every
george: everything seems still, everything's everything. Everything seems still still, still, still still quite accessible, quite accessible, and stuff which is good for sure. Which is good for sure. But okay. But I didn't notice that I didn't notice the play. The the the play button. So
george: the play button itself. It's something being a little bit finicky and stuff, and and
george: a little bit a little bit finicky and stuff. And and when the video plays obvious and the video, and when we and when the video plays obvious with the sound on us interferes with the commands which which I wanted to mention for sure. Yeah,
george: continue on continue on
george: click next, activity.
george: okay, click, next, activity.
george: show links
george: come
george: like next activity. No.
george: I mean
george: mouse grid.
george: 8. Come on.
george: 3, 7, click
george: start scrolling down.
george: Umhm.
george: scroll down. click next activity.
george: Joe Lynx
george: show links
george: mouse grid. 8
george:  5,
george: 3 click.
george: The one thing I noticed is is sometimes it's not. It's not
george: sometimes in terms, sometimes in terms, sometimes some something sometimes in terms of the a accessibility aspect, a a aspect of it seems a little, it seems a little less consistent, less consistent, that that less consistent than I wanted, which which
george: which I thought I should mention, cause cause of that good cause. What? I'll try cause we're not trying to click the next activity button before it seem to work fine, but but it's it seems to work fine, but fine, but it seems to work fine, but but a cop
george: but a couple of times just now, but a couple of times just now. Obviously then, it didn't comprehend, so so so after the mouse could come out which which to me seems a little when we inconsistent.
george: So it's
george: So thought I.
george: So yeah, so that so so so far, I should mention mentioned that part as well.  alright.
george:  Umhm.
george: continue continuing on. I'm I'm gonna keep going quickly. Go through the the the course to see anything else pops up.
george: scroll down.
george: click next activity.
george: Hmm.
george: yeah. Scroll down.
george: Click, next activity.
george: click, start quiz
george: show links.
george: Choose 19. Okay?
george: Okay, so so
george: so okay, I'm not gonna go. I'm not gonna go to.
george: Hmm,
george:  not gonna go through the not gonna go through the whole process, the whole process, but but basically all the all the but basically ma, but basically majority of majority of the app
george: majority aspect of the quiz. Sorry, not the quiz majority aspect of the
george: oh.
george: huh?
george: Majority ask majority asking of the course.
george: And I don't.
george: Yeah. Yeah.
george: And
george:  majority aspect and majority ask majority aspect of the course seems pretty accessible, but pretty accessible, and easy to navigate. With the with the bottom.
george: What the such as even like the the the the quiz buttons, even the quiz quiz, even the quiz buttons, and everything buttons, buttons, and everything see being visible, being very busy, being very visible, and they
george: being very, being very visible and big, big and accessible, which is, which is good to see. just those just those main points I mentioned before about the the, the inconsistent, the inconsistency of the of the of the buttons, not not working sometimes, and then and then the video, and then that.
george: And then the video playback video, video, video, playback.
george: video, playback and video play, video play.
george: video, video, playback interruption playback interruption pro problem that I encounter. Besides those parts besides those parts
george: besides those besides, though besides those 2 parts, those 2, those 2 parts of the problem, besides those 2 parts, the problems that I that I just mentioned. It. It seems to be over.
george: It seems to be overall overall over we over it. It. It it's it's it's
george: it, it seem it's it seems to be. It seems to be over a well, it seems to be overall, well designed and and and still so significantly accessible, which is good to see.
george: Okay.
george: now, I'm gonna now. I'm gonna close the course itself, and and and then just test the rest rest of the rest, the rest rest of the aspects of the of the the the course course platform itself, just to see, make sure, and then that should be good
george: post time.
george: Hmm, hmm, hmm!
george: Show links.
george: Choose one
george: start scrolling down.
george: Scroll up.
george: show links
george: 2, 7.
george: Choose 7
george: show links.
Choose one.
george: Yeah. So, so, so, so, so overall, I'm assuming is overall in terms of the, in terms of the course, in terms of the courses, in terms of the courses itself.
george: the courses itself, and the feedback I gave the feedback I gave. It still stands, and it it still stands. It's still.
george: it still stands. It still stands. And and it's the same and stuff in terms of the actual. Okay, the actual dashboard, the platform, I guess. Platform, I guess, for for rest.
george: The platform, I guess the platform, I guess, for the for the rest of the stuff. As you seen the current current screen and stuff
george: everything seems to be. Everything seems to be very simple, very simple, and it tells you where to go, and it tells you where to go, and and it? Which part of the which part which? Which?
george: Which? Which? Which part of the website, which? Which? Which part? Which part of the website is it which which
george: which, which.
george: which.
george: which part, which, which? Which? Which part of the website it tells you which part of the website does does what and stuff and and where it's located, what to do, where to go on Zoom Phone. So so over us, it's very easy to follow, which is which is definitely good to see. And then, and accessibility, like I said before, is, it's just. It's near perfect, except
george: it's near perfect. It's near perfect. It's near perfect, except this, it's near perfect, except those 2 main points that I mentioned about the the video and and and the inconsistency. But but other than that, it's zoom seems to be very good. So it's the zoom so definitely.
george: definitely. A good start for sure. Thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you so much. Thank you. So thank you. Thank thank you. Thank you.
george: Thank you. Thank thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much. Thank you so much for going through this workbook workflow work full with me, workflow with me. I really appreciate it. Hope you guys have a great day and thank you so much again. Bye.